December cannot come soon enough for
Star Wars fans who are collectively
losing their minds over the rise of
Skywalker so that moment when you guys
come out there I mean that's a real rock
star I'm like this is what it feels like
to be ariana grande it's such a frenzy
of hair any people get so excited is
there a small part of you that wanted to
scream out the ending go guys I'm sorry
or do that fans were seriously shook
when they got their first look at the
new Star Wars movie all because of this
two second shot has Daisy Ridley gone to
the dark side because in the footage
you're holding a red light guide you
hold the red saber everybody has a dark
side and we see this platform in this
character and it was very fun to play
and it'll be very fun to watch also
revealed that Disney's biennial d23
convention an emotional moment of Carrie
Fisher's final performance as Princess
Leia while she passed before Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker went into
production director JJ Abrams was able
to write scenes around old outtakes to
bring her storyline full circle
bittersweet though because you know that
this is the last installment and you're
with these folks that you've done so
much I'm salty he's got stank face
[Music]